Robert Muller drops the mic Democrats
pick it up and did President Trump hide
the USS John McCain like an entire ship
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show a lot going on in the news most of
it chaotic and confusing but don't worry
we will iron it all out for you when you
leave today you will be just graced with
a clarity that never before had to send
it upon you so prepare for suffer that's
gonna be amazing but first hiring used
to be difficult multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process today hiren can be easy only
have to go to one place to get it done
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there but they're powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm slash
daily Wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire if you are looking
to upgrade your business or you're just
looking to bring in some new employees
the best way to do it zip recruit are
gonna save you time gonna save you money
zip recruiters comm slash daily wire and
try them out for free that's zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire alright
so it is the day after Robert motors big
press conference woo and Muller spoke
and it was amazing and the heads
exploded and okay so let's analyze what
exactly
Robert Muller said because everybody
seems a little more confused today than
they were yesterday because Muller did
not clarify anything in fact Muller
basically just threw fuel on the fire of
impeachment talk without actually adding
any new information to the mix there was
no real reason for his statement the
only thing I think it revealed is that
the purpose of his investigation was
always confused and confusing so I want
to go through what Muller actually said
because there were a few key messages in
his valedictory speech so he began his
statement by recognizing that his
original brief was to investigate
Russia's interference in the 2016
presidential election here's what Muller
had to say this was his original brief
remember this is why he was hired okay
it wasn't really about obstruction he
was hired specifically with regard to
the Trump Russia collusion stuff the
first half of his report or he basically
found nothing of importance two years
ago the acting Attorney General asked me
to serve as special counsel and he
created a special counsel's office the
appointment order directed the office to
investigate Russian interference in the
2016 presidential election
this included investigating any links or
coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign as alleged by
the grand jury in an indictment Russian
intelligence officers who were part of
the Russian military launched a
concerted attack on our political system
yep is it is so this this was his
original brief his original brief was
the rush of stuff and then it quickly
morphed into the obstruction stuff and
that is the stuff we were talking about
today why because the Russian stuff
turned out to be basically nothing and
this is what's got Trump fulminating
this morning after two years of hearing
that he was a Russian tool now the case
is that Donald Trump was involved in
obstruction of the fact that he was not
in fact a Russian tool and he's very
upset about all of this and I think
rightly so so President Trump tweeted
out this morning about this Russia
Russia Russia that's all you heard at
the beginning of this witch-hunt hoax
Marshall Marshall Marshall and now
Russia has disappeared because I had
nothing to do with Russia helping me to
get elected it was a crime that didn't
exist so now the Thames and their
partner the fake news media say he
fought back against this phony crime
that didn't exist the surrenders false
accusation and he shouldn't fight back
you should sit back and take it could
this be obstruction no Muller didn't
find obstruction either presidential
harassment exclamation point now I don't
think there's a lot in this tweet that
is deeply wrong that phraseology that
people are using against Trump here is
actually from that first tweet in that
first week Trump says I had nothing to
do with Russia helping me to get elected
and people are jumping on the
phraseology Russia helping me to get
elected because this is Trump's first
admission that Russia was trying to get
him elected something that he has denied
for a very long time that's also Trump
just being awkward on Twitter
because that's what Trump does for a
living Trump clarified this in a
statement to the press afterward he said
Russia didn't help me get elected Russia
was just trying to interfere with the
election he's trying to walk back what
he said in his tweet all of this is is
not useful to the president at the very
least you know who got me elected
I got me elected Russia didn't help me
at all Russia if anything I think help
the other side what you ought to ask us
is do you think the media helped Hillary
Clinton get elected she didn't make it
but you take a look at collusion between
Hillary Clinton and the media you take a
look at collusion between Hillary
Clinton and Russia she had more to do in
the campaign with Russia than I did I
had nothing to do I help I helped get me
elected as pretty is pretty astonishing
stuff that's pretty good stuff and
meanwhile the second message that Muller
put forward really and this is where I
think Trump does have a right to be
somewhat outraged by the extent of the
investigation is that really never
should have included obstruction and
Muller was giving these mixed messages
yesterday in his farewell message here
these mixed messages about why he was
investigating obstruction in the first
place so he moved on to this explanation
unlike the election interference
investigation which started as a
counterintelligence investigation inside
the FBI the obstruction investigation
began as a criminal investigation it was
not an investigation of Russia it was an
investigation of Trump and his
associates for criminal activity but
Muller said yesterday he did not
actually have the authority to conclude
that investigation Muller said regarding
Russian interference that it was
critical to obtain a full and accurate
information from every person they
questioned but he also explained that
the president can't be charged with the
federal crime so if he can't be charged
with a federal crime then what exactly
were you investigating like you don't
have that the police cannot investigate
me for a crime that doesn't exist in
that I can't be charged for that is not
their purview and yet here was Muller
saying I knew from the very start I
could not indict the sitting president
so then what the hell was he doing
standing department policy a president
president
cannot be charged with a federal crime
while he is in office that is
unconstitutional even if the charge is
kept under seal and hidden from public
view that too is prohibited the special
counsels office is part of the
Department of Justice and by regulation
it was bound by that department policy
charging the president with a crime was
therefore not an option we could
consider yeah so then what are what were
you doing right everybody's looking
around today going so what was this all
about if you could not consider a
prosecution at any point and you were
unwilling to recommend impeachment
straight out or say that the president
committed a crime straight out he wasn't
even willing to say the president
committed a crime in the absence of the
DOJ statute didn't even do that right
you just said I'm not going to come to a
conclusion on that because I can't
indict and because I can't indict I'm
not going to formally accuse the
president right this is the second thing
that is the the sort of second aspect of
this he says the DOJ cannot even utilize
the criminal justice system to formally
accuse the president if he can't be
indicted
it is 2d here is it here's Muller
explaining that one the opinion says
that the Constitution requires a process
other than the criminal justice system
to formally accuse a sitting president
of wrongdoing ok so then what were you
doing what was this all about and this
is what drives the the actual reason for
thinking that Muller was was looking for
impeachment he has no other rationale
for doing this he himself says I can't
indict him
I can't even accuse him such that an
indictment would be appropriate so if I
can't do either of those things and why
am I doing this so he says well maybe
we're doing it because we need to make
sure that the memories are fresh
memories of what evidence of what right
here's here's this excuse for the
investigation the opinion explicitly
explicitly permits the investigation of
a sitting president because it is
important to preserve evidence while
memories are fresh and documents
available that evidence could be used if
there were co-conspirators who could be
charged now but there were no
co-conspirators charged now in
obstruction there were no crimes alleged
by Muller
so then what the hell was all of this
about the answer is what this really was
about his impeachment right that that's
really what this was about he said that
there was a process but the process was
basically constitutional in nature in
other words I did this as a predicate to
impeachment I think it's the only way to
read Muller's press conference which
means that he was acting as a tool for
the legislative branch inside the
executive branch which is
unconstitutional he is a member of the
legislature he's a member of the
executive branch the executive branch is
unitary he does not work for Congress he
works for the president people who work
for the president typically are not
charged with investigating the president
this is why for a long time there was
something called the Independent Counsel
Act which made a member of the executive
branch subject to the legislature in
Justice Scalia famously wrote that he
thought that this was unconstitutional
that the idea of having an independent
counsel who doesn't really work for the
President and also doesn't really work
for the Congress that creates a weird
fourth branch of government that doesn't
really exist so the only takeaway from
this is basically that Muller wanted
Trump to go down but he wouldn't call
for prosecution here is Muller
explaining that effectively there was
insufficient evidence to charge a
broader conspiracy if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so we did not however make a
determination as to whether the
President did commit a crime we
concluded that we would would not reach
a determination one way or the other
about whether the president committed a
crime in what in the world I mean this
is it's an amazing statement right what
he's saying here is we won't willing to
charge a crime we couldn't charge a
crime because of indictment but we're
not going to exonerate the president
that was one minute after he said this
quote it would be unfair to potentially
accuse somebody of a crime when there
can be no court resolution of the actual
charge and then he proceeded to say well
I can't exonerate him so you pulled the
James Comey he pulled the James Comey
and you remember the Chamber's call me
the former FBI director basically went
out there and said Hillary Clinton is
guilty as sin but I'm changing the law
in order to let her off the hook and a
lot of folks are like whoa that seems
wildly inappropriate why exactly is he
doing that and a lot of people called
for James coming to be fired based on
that I was one of them now
have robert muller basically doing the
same thing you have muller doing the
exact same thing
okay so muller I think actually dragged
himself through the mud here and I think
he dragged himself through the mud now
there's one thing that he said that I
think cut in favor of the Attorney
General Bill Barr who's also become a
target of Democrats we'll get to that in
just a second but first did you know
that Millennials have three times as
much student debt as their parents
that's not right but you can get your
student loans right by refinancing your
loans with sofa I know tons of folks
from hundreds of thousands of dollars of
student loan debt it's really holding
them back well this is where so Phi
comes in so Phi is the leading student
loan refinance er in the United States
they've refinanced hundreds of thousands
of student loans it's fast it's easy
it's all online you can check your rate
in two minutes and lock in a fixed low
rate refinancing your student loans it
could save you thousands of bucks
lowering that interest rate or choosing
one of sofas flexible terms could help
you save thousands when you refinance
their student loans with so Phi you can
also get access to so Phi membership
giving you access to exclusive benefits
to help you get ahead with your money
life and career to lock in a fixed low
rate today at sofa comm slash man that's
SOF i.com slash man listen I'm of the
generation that took out a lot of
student debt I know so many people who
might need help refinancing that set so
they can move on with their lives and
help consolidate those payments so Phi
comm slash Ben that's sof i.com
slash man so Phi lending Corp CFL number
six zero five four six one two already
so back to Robert Miller the one thing
the Miller said the cut in favor of the
Trump administration is he basically
suggested the bill bar the Attorney
General was not trying to hide anything
here's his explanation of this we
conducted an independent criminal
investigation and reported the results
to the Attorney General as required by
Department regulations the Attorney
General then concluded that it was
appropriate to provide our report to
Congress and to the American people at
one point in time I requested that
certain portions of the report be
released the Attorney General prepared
preferred to make that and preferred to
make the entire report public all at
once and we appreciate that the Attorney
General made the report largely public
and I certainly did not question the
Attorney General's good faith in that
decision okay so there he is
undercutting the
Democratic line that bill bar has been
lying to them consistently the Attorney
General of the United States and the
line consistently now the media are not
letting go the idea that bill Barr lied
so they've been playing on a loop these
sort of contradictions between robert
muller statements and william bars
statements before congress so they're a
couple of contrasts between the
statements that we have to analyze to
see who's lying or who's telling the
truth or if there's really any conflict
to begin with
i'll point out that the supposed
conflicts were cleared up quasi in a way
by kerry kupack the spokeswoman for the
department justice and Peter Carr the
spokesman for the special counsels
office they're released a joint
statement right after Muller statement
they said quote the Attorney General has
previously stated that the special
counsel repeatedly affirmed that he was
not saying that but for the OLC opinion
he would have found the president
obstructed justice the special counsels
report and his statement today made
clear that the office concluded it would
not reach a determination one way or the
other about whether the president
committed a crime there's no conflict
between these statements I pointed this
out yesterday in our analysis that when
Muller said that the DOJ regulations
prohibited from reaching him prohibited
him from reaching a conclusion that did
not actually contradict the statement
made by bar that Muller said that even
in the absence of the OLC ruling he
might not have prosecuted the president
there is no conflict between those two
points but let's play some of these
clips back to back bar versus Muller on
for example the evidence of collusion
because there does seem to be some
shading that is going on here here is
William bar talking about the evidence
of collusion versus what what Robert
Muller had to say about evidence of
collusion the special counsels report
did not find any evidence that members
of the Trump campaign or anyone
associated with the campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government in these hacking operations
in other words there was no evidence of
the Trump campaign collusion with the
Russian government's hacking the first
volume of the report details numerous
efforts emanating from Russia to
influence the election this volume
includes a discussion of the Trump
campaigns response to this activity as
well as our conclusion that there was
insufficient evidence to charge a
broader conspiracy and those two things
are not actually in conflict so you have
Muller
that there is insufficient evidence of
conspiracy that is a softer thing than
no evidence of collusion but conspiracy
and collusion are two different things
conspiracies in actual criminal charge
collusion is a general political
accusation so when when bar says there's
no evidence of collusion that's correct
and when Muller says there's
insufficient evidence of conspiracy that
is also correct because conspiracy is a
criminal charge collusion is not a legal
term so the purported conflict between
Barr and Muller on this point I don't
find particularly convincing in a second
we'll get to the other supposed conflict
between Barr and Muller so there's
another conflict supposedly between
William Barr the Attorney General's
testimony and what Robert Muller said in
his statement yesterday and this one
surrounded obstruction of justice so
here's what Barr had to say vs. what
Muller had to say after carefully
reviewing the facts and legal theories
outlined in the report and in
consultation with the Office of Legal
Counsel and other department lawyers the
Deputy Attorney General and I concluded
that the evidence developed by the
special counsel is not sufficient to
establish that the president committed
an obstruction of justice offense if we
had had confidence that the president
clearly did not commit a crime we would
have said so we did not however make a
determination as to whether the
president did commit a crime okay those
two things again are not in conflict
when William Barr says right there that
the obstruction of justice evidence
isn't sufficient for a prosecution that
is the same thing effectively as Robert
Miller saying we can't exonerate him but
also we didn't recommend prosecution
again Barr was using a legal standard
and Muller is going further than that I
think that President Trump frankly has
reason to be angry at Robert Muller I'm
a little more upset at Robert Muller
today than I have been for a couple of
years I've been very much in Robert
Miller's corner I believe that this is a
guy who is trying to do his job but I
think it appeared from his statements
yesterday that he surpassed his original
brief and that his original brief was
not supposed to encompass a lot of the
stuff that he ended up doing if Congress
wants to investigate this stuff that is
their purview they have every right to
do that but to effectively become a tool
for impeachment was beyond his mandate
those beyond the scope of his man
now what has happened effectively
speaking is that all of this has now
been tossed into the lap of Congress
which is where it should have begun in
the first place if Democrats want to
impeach they have every ability to do
that the media were blowing this up
suggesting that Robert Muller had now
made the case for impeachment the
editorial board over at The Washington
Post says quote Special Counsel Robert
Muller broke his long silence Wednesday
telling a news conference that his
two-year Russia investigation is closed
and that he did not have anything to say
publicly beyond what was written in the
report but the key passages he chose to
highlight underline the dishonesty of
President Trump and Attorney General
William Barr in seeking to dodge and
mischaracterized his conclusions the
central allegations of the investigators
Muller said was that there were multiple
systemic efforts to interfere in our
elections yet today it has not been
fully acknowledged by mr. Trump okay
that's fair enough Trump has constantly
said that he doesn't think that it was
important that Russia basically
interfered in the election that's a fair
criticism but that's not really a
criticism a bar then the Washington Post
says mr. Brown claimed there was not a
case to be made against mr. Trump for
obstruction of justice based on Miller's
findings so significant that Muller
restated what his report actually says
that if we had confidence the president
clearly did not commit a crime we would
have said so again those two things are
not in conflict this is the Washington
Post creating a falsehood
when Barr says there was not a case to
be made that it was not sufficiently
prosecutable that is not in conflict
with Muller saying that we can't
exonerate we can't exonerate and we can
prosecute our two very different terms
we can't exonerate OJ Simpson but we
also can't prosecute him he's already
been acquitted there are a lot of
reasons why you can't prosecute someone
who also cannot be exonerated this
happens legitimately all the time in the
American criminal justice system mr.
Muller could have avoided much confusion
and short-circuited the administration's
attempt to manipulate public opinion
says the Washington Post if he had made
his statement weeks ago in conjunction
with the release of a lightly redacted
version of his report so the Washington
Post continues to try to claim that
there's some cover-up that went on even
though Muller explicitly said there was
no cover-up that went on in the middle
of this press conference
the left is is basically hoping to hang
their hat on mullahs press conference
and what's amazing is that they continue
to call out from Muller to do the work
they won't do here's the problem for the
Democrats and for the left now the ball
is in their court and they
don't actually want the ball in their
Court they want Muller to come back
there's like the end of Shane you got
Brandon Brandon Wilder out there on the
plains shouting out for shame to come
back there's a there's there's a Robert
Robert I mean just calling across the
play and Muller is just riding away into
that painted distance that's all that's
going on here
like Robert De Niro it's so funny Robert
De Niro why he has an opinion column in
the New York Times is beyond me Robert
De Niro is most famous for reading lines
other people write for him but he played
Muller on SNL and this apparently means
he has expertise on obstruction the
power of celebrity pretty incredible so
Robert De Niro has a piece in the New
York Times called Robert Muller we need
to hear more and it's an open letter to
Robert Muller from Robert De Niro in The
New York Times
yes everything is insanely stupid says
dear mr. Muller it probably hasn't
escaped your attention that I play a
version of you on Saturday Night Live
yes because that was deeply important to
Robert Muller I'm sure he sits up every
night thinking about you
as Robert Muller my character is
intimidating because he is so honest and
upright I do it for comic effect that's
the intention anyway but there's also a
lot of truth to it to put it another way
it's good natured fun but not entirely
good-natured there's a level of satire
directed at the current administration
to be fair not everyone appreciates the
humor the president has tweeted there's
nothing funny about tired Saturday Night
Live and that it's very unfair and
should be looked into the what or with
whom the show would be colluding is
unclear but then I don't have to tell
you about problems with the terms
collusion collusion you barely mention
the word in your report and then only to
explain why you're not using it that
could be a punchline on Saturday Night
Live how does this crap get through the
editorial process at the New York Times
truly this is incoherent gibberish on
the so glad Roberts is like Martin Sheen
sounding off on presidential executive
orders because he once played a
president on television it's a joke in
and of itself Robert DeNiro says as I
prepared for my role on the show I got
to know you a lot better I read about
your lifetime devotion to public service
and your respect for the rule of law I
watched how you presided over the
special counsel's office apparently
without leaks and you never wavered even
in the face of regular vicious attacks
from the president and his surrogates
well I and so many Americans have
admired your quiet confident dignified
response and ignoring that a
salt and allowed the administration to
use its own voice to control the
narrative there's a lot of speculation
about the president being tone deaf to
facts but there's not much disagreement
about the tone whether you take delight
in it as his loyal supporters do or
you're the unfortunate target of his
angry rhetoric the hostile way he
expresses himself registers with anyone
say what you will about the president
and I have when it comes to that lie
exaggerating bullying thing no one can
touch him and here mr. Miller is where
you come in what do you need to come in
in your news conference you said that
your investigations work speaks for
itself it doesn't it may speak for
itself to lawyers and lawmakers who have
the patience an obligation to read
through the more than 400 pages of
carefully chosen words and nuanced
conclusions you've characterized the
report as your testimony but you
wouldn't accept that reason from anyone
your office interviewed additional
information and illumination emerge from
responses to questions I know you're
uncomfortable in the spotlight as the
president is out of it I know you don't
want to become part of the political
spectacle I know you will however
reluctantly testify before Congress have
called because you respect the system
and follow the rules so much heroism you
are the voice of the malla report let
the country hear that voice with great
respect Robert senior oh come back come
back Shane why won't you just tell why
why why won't you just please come back
Robert oh my goodness it's just amazing
just amazing stuff
well Muller isn't coming back and his
report does say what it says and that
means that it's basically up to the
Democrats now whether they want to
impeach we're gonna get to that in just
one second first four decades credit
cards have been telling us buy it now
and pay it later with interest despite
your best intentions that interest can
get out of control fast with Lending
Club you can consolidate your debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment since 2007 Lending Club
is how millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com you tell them
that yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash Ben check your
eight minutes power up to forty grand no
reason you should be suffering with
those high interest rates get your
finances in order
head on over to Lending Club comm slash
Ben that is
in club.com /ban all loans made by Webb
mang member FDIC Equal Housing lender
again that's Lending Club dot-com / bent
doesn't take very long to find out how
much you can get and what your rate is
check your eight minutes power up to
forty grand that's Lending Club comm
/ban Lending Club comm / bettin alright
so the left has now responded to all of
this they now recognize that impeachment
is what's on the table this was best
summed up by Chris Matthews I'm that
mistake I think I'm very excited after
mother's statement get up coming up they
show come on in here let's go Robert
mother talk pretty amazing and then and
then we talk about impeachment love
impeachment pretty great like peaches
impeaching all sorts of great things go
for months now they said well we just
want to hear from this we just want to
hear from the Senate we need a
Republican senator or we want to hear
from another witness we want to hear
from Papadopoulos who else want to hear
from Carter page they want to hear from
mower they're not gonna hear from it
mower this is it so the train whistles
blowing and Pelosi has got to make a
decision and it can't be a waiting game
like I'm being audited like Trump plays
it can't be a game of kicking the can
down the road it's now or no or never
and I think that's the tough question
for has always been are you willing to
say no to impeachment and I think it's
totally up in the air what she's going
to do I mean the train is leaving the
station I love trains they go choo choo
and chugga chugga if you're not on that
train you're in front of the train Nancy
Pelosi are you gonna be on the train
Nancy Pelosi get on the train Nancy or
don't get on the train I don't care go
back home and play with my trains ah
Chris Matthews I miss me sick the but
he's not wrong hmm I'm mocking him
because he's Chris Matthews but he is
not in fact incorrect
what Muller did here he basically said
okay Congress this one's on you enjoy
yourself and Nancy Pelosi has not a lot
of taste for this and corny McClatchy
most congressional Democrats heard one
message in Robert Mullins public
statement on Wednesday it's up to you to
punish President Donald Trump but House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi signaled
unwillingness on one state to take a
leap that many on the political left
have already made impeachment
investigating and potentially impeaching
Trump dominated Capitol Hill talk on
Wednesday but behind closed doors were
influential Democrats urged starting an
inquiry and out loud among progressives
demanding
hello see did not utter the word
Wednesday in a terse five paragraph
statement issued two hours after Muller
left it to Congress to investigate Trump
further the Congress holds sacred its
constitutional responsibility to
investigate and hold the president
accountable for his abuse of power the
Congress will continue to investigate in
legislate to protect our elections and
secure our democracy the American people
must have the truth
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba now the reality is that
the House Judiciary Committee has not
been calling the proper witnesses
they've met up in subpoena the proper
witnesses they've not been asking the
proper questions in fact it is not even
clear that they are going to subpoena
Robert Muller in all of this there are
rumors floating around Capitol Hill
yesterday that even Democrats don't want
Muller to testify for a couple of
reasons one Muller may get up there and
say yeah I didn't reach a determination
on obstruction that's up to you guys I'm
not gonna sit here and do your work for
you I was not allowed to do that by the
by the rules of the DOJ and I didn't
reach a conclusion
so maybe Democrats don't want to hear
that message there's also the
possibility that I was hearing that
Democrats are concerned that Muller will
look bad in front of Republicans will
say okay so why did you even do this
stuff in the first place if the DOJ
prohibited you from the very beginning
from either recommending and indictments
or inciting yourself here's Jerry Nadler
yesterday basically acknowledging that
he is not interested in calling Robert
Muller which is an amazing switch for
the Democrats remember Robert Muller was
the most important person to hear from
for the Democrats for two years for two
years they're buying votive candles for
two years they were suggesting that
Robert Miller is going to save them from
Trump and even for the past two months
since William Barr released his
four-page letter the Democrats have been
claiming that we need to hear directly
from Muller
well Muller spoke yesterday for a grand
total about nine minutes and 40 seconds
and that's all they're gonna get and
Democrats apparently are satisfied with
that which suggests maybe they know
they're not gonna get much more out of
Muller that is going to benefit them
here is Nadler the head of the House
Judiciary Committee effectively saying
yeah I'm not interested in calling
Muller at this point mr. Muller told us
a lot of what we need to hear today it's
very important to be clear on what he
told us and what the special precedent
old the American people he reaffirmed
what was in the investigation which
which was in the report about the
investigation which found substantial
evidence that Russia attacked our
political system that the Trump campaign
benefited from Russia's interference
that Trump and those around them
repeatedly welcomed Russia's support and
that throughout the investigation Trump
sought to obstruct justice and undermine
Muller and the investigation over and
over again okay well again he's saying
I'm not gonna call Muller we got all we
need
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do but here's
the reality the Democrats are not gonna
do anything here they're not going to do
anything here they're going to they're
gonna smear Trump they're gonna suggest
that Trump engaged in obstruction of
justice the 2020 Democrats are going to
suggest that Trump is impeachable
without actually having to own all of
this Kamala Harris yesterday said
absolutely we've got to impeach and
she's indicative of the general
Democratic mindset at this point what
was a message that mr. Muller was
sending to you a sitting member of
Congress and do you have a reaction to
the president's tweet saying that this
case is closed and nothing has changed
well I don't try not to respond to those
tweets but I will say that I think what
is clear is that it's I think it's a
fair inference from what we heard in
that press conference that Bob Muller
was essentially referring impeachment to
the United States Congress okay so she
actually went further than that on MSNBC
she actually said the president in Trump
should be prosecuted and locked up so we
have shifted from lock her up to lock
him up and Kamala Harris has a long
history of attempting to lock people up
many times unjustly here is Kamala
Harris saying that the president should
go to jail
I am also clear from reading what he
wrote in that report that the only
reason they did not return an indictment
against this president on obstruction of
justice is because of a an opinion from
the Department of Justice that suggests
that you cannot indict a sitting
president but there is no question that
the evidence supports a prosecution of
that case so taking it to the point of
your next question
absolutely okay so this is easy for the
20/20 candidates to say
it's not so easy for Nancy Pelosi they
are going to slow play it despite Chris
Matthews saying that it's time for the
Democrats to poop or get off the pot
they are not going to do that Nancy
Pelosi is going to slow play this Nancy
Pelosi is not interested in moving
forward with impeachment she's got too
many moderate members of her own caucus
who exist in suburban areas where the
vote is closely split and she's deeply
afraid that those people lose their
seats as McClatchy reports
representative Lucy Macbeth Georgia
Democrat who won her seat last year with
50.5% in a district trump narrowly won
in 2016
refuses to mention impeachment she says
we need the full Mullah report it's
underlying evidence we need this
administration to stop stonewalling
Congress blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah the Democrats in moderate areas are
not going to talk impeachment Pelosi
knows it there is not the support in the
Democratic caucus for impeachment right
now so all this has become is just more
political fodder which means in the end
it doesn't mean anything the American
people are tired of this the American
people are not interested in impeachment
the American people are bored with this
story the American people already came
away with the proper conclusion Trump
was not exonerated on obstruction
because not prosecutable on it and also
this stuff is not impeachable that is
the exact right conclusion Democrats are
not on board with it because it doesn't
fit their story but it is the reality
and Nancy Pelosi knows that full well in
a second we'll get to some other
Democratic strategies for 2020 that are
I think kind of scary for some of
America's freedoms we'll get to that in
just a second first getting fit staying
healthy it always sounds easier said
than done right well open fit is
bringing you something new that makes it
even easier never to miss a sweat
session lose the commute to the gym let
the workouts come to you okay I love
open fit my wife works really long hours
I work some pretty long hours sue one of
the things we like to do at night we get
home we open up open fit and then we
work out together open if it takes all
the complexity out of losing weight and
getting fit it's a brand new super
simple streaming service that allows you
to work out from the comfort of your
living room in as little as 10 minutes a
day everybody's bodies are different
open fit gets that that's why it's
personalized your needs with custom
tailored original content open fit
classes are led by some of the most
effective and engaging trainers in the
world the training sessions are really
terrific forget all the complexity and
stress around getting fit just press
play and work out on your schedule view
on your computer web enabled TV tablet
smartphone and Roku lose up to 15 pounds
in just the first 30 days flat in the
ABS shape
body look and feel great again I love
open fit myself if you are short on time
you don't have time to make that commute
to the gym you don't want to pay that
gym membership you don't have time for
personal trainer it's basically a
personal trainer in your house open fit
has changed the way I workout and with
my coach Shapiro you can join me on a
fitness journey personalized for you
again use that code Shapiro and start
using open fit for your journey to a
healthier life right now during the open
fit 30-day challenge my listeners get a
special extended 30-day free trial
membership to open fit you can lose up
to 15 pounds in 30 days text Shapiro -
30 30 30 get full access to open fit
workouts nutrition information totally
free text Shapiro - 30 30 30 okay we're
gonna get two other Democratic
strategies for 2020 coming up strategies
that are gonna have some pretty
significant implications for your
freedoms first head on over to Taylor
wire and subscribe for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily wire
when you do you get the rest of the show
live you also get two additional hours
of the show every day we are working to
bring you all the up to date information
basically our show goes all day long so
if you want to be part of that all you
have to do is go subscribe also when you
do subscribe to get access to our Sunday
specials and our Sunday special this
week is really I think an amazing Sunday
special I interviewed several people
several former members of the military
who served at Normandy because of course
June 6 D Day is coming up I think it's
something really moving and worthwhile
something that you're gonna want to show
to your kids and your friends here's a
little bit of that let's say after my
18th birthday I was called up I was 18
years of age hundred twelve pounds
I flew 36 combat missions over Germany I
was a medic we were just assigned a
mission and happened to be d-day landing
mainly it was chaos I was so frightened
I was blacked up and then my mind was
flashing through there's a son father
that won't be coming home the reason
you're sitting here today is because of
what we did this is exactly true go
check it out it's the 75th anniversary
of d-day special edition for the Sunday
special you get that on Saturday when
you're a subscriber
there's also extra materials behind the
pay walls you know the extra questions
that I asked these amazing human beings
go check it out I think it's really
really worthwhile I also get the annual
subscription for 99 bucks
along with that comes this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist years hot or cold tumbler it is
indeed magical please subscribe also
over at YouTube or iTunes give us a
review that always helps tell your
friends about it we appreciate we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so there there's some other tactics
that Democrats are trying for 2020 I
don't think impeachment is gonna be
sufficient for them for 2020 cuz I don't
think they're actually going to pursue
it well the the other tactic they're
trying for 2020 is the sort of nefarious
tactic where they signal to social media
companies that social media companies
ought to shut down material they don't
like this is really dangerous stuff so I
think after 2016 Democrats refused to
acknowledge that Hillary Clinton was a
garbage candidate who lost because she
was a garbage candidate instead it must
have been Russian election interference
instead it must have been Facebook and
fake news and all these other excuses
well one of the things they are focused
like a laser on is that come 2020 they
do not want alternative methods of
distribution to the mainstream media and
so they're focusing on on social media
companies they're threatening them with
legislation they're threatening them
with regulation and so you have the
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi now
suggesting that because there was a
video of her on Facebook just of her
slowed down a little bit so it sounded
like she was drunk a little bit like
this humorous video this shows that the
Facebook leaders wittingly helped the
Russians wittingly helped I mean this is
a nefarious accusation there is no way
in hell that the Facebook leadership
that Mark Zuckerberg was like yeah I'm
helping the Russians throw this election
to trump I'm sure that was going through
my risako bruised head nor is it the job
of Mark Zuckerberg to censor stuff on
his platform that is not illegal
that is not Mark Zuckerberg job I've
been saying for a very long time that to
treat the social media companies as
though they are the ultimate arbres of
good and evil of truth and falsity is
simply nonsense if you want to say that
Facebook should remove things that
violate the law violent incitement
slanderous materials copyright
violations fine but if you want to say
that Facebook is supposed to remove
everything Nancy Pelosi doesn't like or
they unwittingly helped the Russians or
in her case she says wittingly helped
the Russians this is in a pretty close
to overt threat against Facebook design
to get facebook to change its policies
in advance of the 2020 election that's
what's going on here when something like
facebook says I know this is false but
we're it's a lie but we're showing it
anyway well if to me it says two things
one is that they probably I was giving
them the benefit of their down on Russia
but clearly they I thought it was
unwitting
clearly they wittingly were accomplices
and enablers of false information to go
across Facebook yeah justjust ridiculous
so Facebook was apparently according to
Nancy Pelosi wittingly helping Trump win
the election with the help so it didn't
have facebook is Mark Zuckerberg who
colluded with the Russians according to
Nancy Pelosi this is her threatening
Facebook and it's not just her Hillary
Clinton who can never accept the fact
that she lost the election because she's
the worst candidate ever that's the
actual story of the election
everybody has created this weird mythos
about the last 10 years in American
politics where Barack Obama was not the
electoral outlier Barack Obama was the
new normal and because Barack Obama was
the new normal Trump's victory was some
unbelievably shocking thing where he
built this brand new coalition know the
actual story is this Hillary Clinton is
the normal Democrat Barack Obama is the
abnormal Democrat Donald Trump got
basically the same percentages as normal
Republicans do even though he is an
abnormal Republican so when he beat
Hillary Clinton that was mostly about
Hillary sucking at her job about her not
being able to hold the new gains that
Barack Obama had made and yet for
Hillary Clinton it's all Facebook's
fault so here is she's making the same
point all of this is designed to softly
push not so softly push Mark Zuckerberg
and Jack Dorsey over at Twitter and the
people over at Google to basically bias
their tech in favor of Democrats come
2020 that's what this is about right
here it's dangerous stuff Facebook
refused to take down a fake video of
Nancy Pelosi it wasn't even a close call
the video is sexist trash and YouTube
took it down but Facebook kept it up so
let's send a message to Facebook that
those who are are in Facebook's
communities would really like Facebook
to pay attention to false and doctored
videos before we are flooded with them
over the next month
okay this idea that she's gonna cram
down on Facebook her vision of what is
true and what is false is gonna get
dangerous very very quickly it's not
restricted to the United States by the
way the left is on the move across the
world in terms of trying to crack down
on social media because they don't like
the idea of free platforms my view on
this and I've been targeted by a lot of
people on social media for things
to an including death and so I'm very
well aware of social media being misused
but trying to crack down on social media
as a platform and instead turn it into
some sort of left-wing publishing site
that's what a lot of folks on the left
one it's created an enormous amount of
blowback in Germany where Angela
Merkel's heir apparent is facing
criticism her name is Anna grant Crump
Karen Bauer she replaced Merkel as the
leader of the ruling CDU last year
that's Merkel's party she denied that
she was promoting censorship after her
comments which were prompted by a
YouTube video by a popular 26 year old
blogger named Rizzo in the video seen by
millions ahead of the EU parliament vote
razo called on voters to reject the two
parties for betraying the young by not
addressing the climate crisis cramp
Karen Bauer said quote I asked myself
what would be the response in this
country and say 70 newspapers issued a
joint appeal two days before the
election saying don't vote CDU or SPD
this would be the sort of central writer
senator left parties she says that would
have been a clear propagandizing before
the election I believe it would have
unleashed a lively debate so the
question remains what are the rules from
the analog era and how do they apply in
the digital era it sounds like she wants
to regulate the social media company she
wants to regulate youtubes that you
can't election year before a campaign
the political class the political elite
do not like the fact that they cannot
control podcasts like this one they do
not like the fact that they cannot
control distribution of information on
Facebook and YouTube and Twitter they
don't like that and so they are
attempting to push pressure cram down
their vision of society on the already
left-leaning leaders of these various
tech companies who are willing to hear
at number one because many of them are
on the left and number two because they
wish to escape the governmental censure
that is going to be promoted by people
like speaker Pelosi and like Hillary
Clinton that's some pretty dangerous
stuff when we say that freedoms are at
issue this is a fundamental freedom that
is at issue right now and meanwhile
president Trump not doing himself any
grand favors with this story so this one
is not really president Trump's fault
apparently there's a story originally
from The Wall Street Journal all about
how the USS John McCain supposedly was
hidden from Donald Trump okay The Wall
Street Journal reported yesterday that
the White House wanted the USS John
McCain out of sight during pres
Trump's visit to Japan they reported US
military officials work to ensure that
President Trump wouldn't see the warship
that bears the name of the late Senator
a frequent target of the president's ire
the story is by Rebecca ball house and
Gordon Liu bald
they say the White House wanted the US
Navy to move out of sight the warship
USS John McCain ahead of President
Trump's visit to Japan the ship was
named after the father and grandfather
of the late Senator a war hero who
became a frequent target of mr. Trump's
ire and the Senators name was added to
the ship in 2018 in a May 15th email to
US Navy and Air Force officials a u.s.
Indo Pacific Command official outlined
plans for the president's arrival in
addition to instructions for proper
landing areas for helicopters and
preparations for the USS Wasp where the
president was scheduled to speak the
official issued a third director USS
John McCain needs to be out of sight
please confirm number three that was
that directive will be satisfied the
official Road when a navy commander
expressed surprise about the directive
for the USS John McCain the u.s.
indo-pacific command official replied
first I heard of it as well
he said he'd work with the White House
military office to obtain more
information acting defense secretary Pat
Shanahan according to The Wall Street
Journal was aware of the concern about
the presence of the USS John McCain in
Japan and approved measures to ensure it
didn't interfere with the president's
visit according to a US official Trump
has fired back on this report he said
quote I was not informed about anything
having to do with the Navy ship USS John
McCain during my recent visit to Japan
nevertheless the first lady and I loved
being with our great military men and
women what a spectacular job they do now
the the Washington Post is reporting
that President Trump has spoken out more
about this he said quote I don't know
what happened I was not involved I would
not have done that he said I was not a
big fan of John McCain in any shape or
form now somebody did it because they
thought I didn't like him okay and they
were well-meaning what's that last line
that's not really great hey they were
well-meaning you know when when your own
staff is trying to protect you from a
ship that has a dead man's name on it
and you didn't like the dead guy that
doesn't speak well of your thin-skinned
earnest when it comes to John McCain but
the fact that Trump didn't know about it
obviously means that you can't put it on
Trump you put it on his staff and his
staff obviously should have just said
whatever it's a ship
and if from can't get over it then it's
then on Trump but from the staffers
I understand you're trying to shield the
president you're trying to prevent a
blow up in public from the President of
the United States the fact that Trump
has these personality foibles is not a
good thing for sure a senior White House
official confirmed on Wednesday the
person who issued the directive did not
want the worship with the McCain name
seen in photographs during Trump's visit
the official who spoke on condition of
anonymity to discuss internal
deliberations said the president was not
involved in the planning but the request
was made to keep Trump from becoming
upset so there are a lot of folks in the
White House apparently who are
attempting to prevent President Trump
from basically feeling quasi angst at
the fact that there is a ship named
after John McCain now it is reported by
the Navy chief of information that the
name of the USS John McCain was not
obscured during the president's visit to
Yokosuka on Memorial Day the Navy is
proud of that ship its crew its namesake
and a-tearin edge Trump himself
obviously tweeted that that he had
nothing to do with this Katy tur reports
from NBC a spokesperson for the US
Pacific Fleet said the picture of a tarp
there's a picture from Friday of a tarp
over the McCain name a spokesperson for
the US Pacific Fleet said the picture of
the tarp is from Friday it was taken
down on Saturday all ships remained in
normal configurations during the
president's visitor said commander Nate
Kristensen so the media did in fact push
this too far the media suggested that
Trump himself was responsible for this
the media suggested that the ship was in
fact hidden when apparently it was not
but a couple of things can be true once
one the media can get overzealous on
these stories to people around the
president need to not protect him from
stings that are stupid if Trump can't
handle it Trump can't handle it it's a
dumb story it's a silly story and
honestly president Trump's you just let
McCain go and people have their opinions
about McCain I didn't like McCain as a
senator particularly much I didn't think
that he was a wonderful senator but he
was a military hero he was an obvious
military hero that deserves all of our
respect and commendation no matter what
I think pretty much everybody agrees on
this so again these sorts of sensitivity
issues for the president need to need to
go away meanwhile in other news this is
a bizarre story out of Israel
so you remember there was just an
Israeli election like five minutes ago
there was like wow look at that and it's
in Yahoo won again well now there's
gonna be another election
I will say here that it is worthwhile
noting that Israel has now had two
elections inside of a year or will have
two elections inside of year that's as
many elections as the Palestinians have
had ever ever because Israel is a
democracy in a wild chaotic functioning
parliamentary democracy at that
nonetheless it's a very weird
circumstance the first time in Israeli
history that an elected governmental
leader has been unable to form a
coalition according to the Washington
Post in a stunning turn Israel will head
to elections for a second time in less
than six months after president Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu failed to
form a government before a midnight
Wednesday deadline rather than gives
someone else the chance to do so his
party advanced a bill to dissolve
Parliament and trigger new elections in
September Netanyahu was enabled to bring
a Vig door Lieberman his former defense
minister into a coalition that would
give the Prime Minister a majority of
Parliament's that's Knesset the two
veteran politicians were at loggerheads
over legislation sought by Lieberman to
draft ultra-orthodox Jews into the
military a measure bitterly resisted by
Netanyahu's powerful political allies in
the religious parties there's a lot of
controversy over over Orthodox service
in the military because the military is
pretty secular place there are what they
call Hester units which are units that
are specifically of the Orthodox and
tend to be more in line with Orthodox
rules the expansion of those hester
units would obviously be the proper
solution here the move for new elections
leaves israel and political disarray as
it now embarks on an expensive
nationwide vote that has no guarantee of
shifting the balance of power among the
parties they're gonna do this again for
no apparent reason it's very awkward
stuff but again proof that a functioning
democracy is still in Israel apparently
there was a vote of 74 to 45 to dissolve
the body just a month after being sworn
in Gil Hoffmann chief political
correspondent for The Jerusalem Post
said this is devastating to the average
Israeli who's really tired of such
selfish politics there's no way to
explain the situation to the average
Israelis or saying their politicians
aren't working for their interests would
not be a surprise means a risky move by
Netanyahu would not be surprised to see
the blue and white party gain seats
because people are angry at Netanyahu
and angry at Lieberman so pretty
fascinating stuff happening over in
Israel alrighty time for some things
that I like and then some things that I
hate so things that I like shannon bream
is just a
under phul person she has a really fun
and inspiring a book called finding the
bright side and it really is just a
memoir from her talking about all of the
issues that she has faced in her career
in her life and it's it's a pretty great
conservative little book it's it's it's
really a lot of fun to reach talks about
her conservative religious upbringing
she talks about going to Liberty
University she talked about how she got
into the TV business and Shannon is the
light of a human and this book is is a
lot of fun and an easy read so go check
it out finding the bright side the art
of chasing what matters it's a kick okay
other things that I like so Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader was
getting a lot of flack over the last
couple of days because he was
specifically asked about whether if Ruth
Bader Ginsberg were to were to leave the
court for example and Trump or
denominator replacement whether they'd
fill that vacancy in the last year of
his presidency now the reason that that
has become an issue is because McConnell
said that the Senate was not going to
vote in the last year of President
Obama's presidency on Merrick garland
now it is also important to note that
Mitch McConnell said at the time the
reason for that is because we have a
split in the parties it is not the job
of a Republican Senate to approve a
Democratic nominee now I've always said
I didn't understand why that logic
obtained only for the last year of a
presidency like why did Mitch McConnell
has to approve of anybody that was put
for that there's an advice and consent
role for Senate the Senate does not have
to approve anybody Mitch McConnell made
it time-bound basically saying if
Hillary won they'd vote on Merrick
garland but there's no reason for him to
say even that in any case Mitch
McConnell was asked if he would fill a
vacancy in the last year of Trump's
first term and McConnell's like yeah for
sure
we fill it okay so people are laughing
because supposedly this is a
hypocritical hard move no hard-nosed
move by McConnell but it and that's
that's very taciturn stuff from from
Mitch McConnell but what he is saying
there is obviously correct the Democrats
are going to approve a Democratic
nominee Republicans will approve a
Republican nominee if there is a split
then at the very least a delay seems
somewhat appropriate I would say the
delay can be indefinite I don't think
that Republicans are bound to vote for
Merrick garland even if Obama had
nominated him in the very first year of
his presidency okay time for some things
that I hate so the the move by major
corporations to virtue signal on
politics is really quite terrible Disney
has now come out and maybe they'll move
their production outside of Georgia if
the Georgia law goes into effect Bob
Iger said that Netflix has said maybe we
will move our production out of Georgia
if Georgia's heartbeat bill goes into
effect well this is about as gutless a
statement as it's possible to make if
you don't like pro-lifers in Georgia
they voted for it pull your money and
then we will know all of us pro-lifers
all of us will know that we just will
not to your movies in fact we can do you
severe damage I see in your movies and
just renting them on Amazon you just
won't go to the theater and pay you 30
bucks a ticket instead we will just wait
till it comes out on Amazon and rent it
for $2.99
and we'll bankrupt you you want to play
this game if the left wants to play this
game where they refuse to do business
with people with whom they disagree on
politics and on crucial issues like
abortion well then they're gonna pay the
price there are plenty of us there are
plenty of us who are not interested in
subscribe and Netflix subscriber I'm
sure a lot of people who are listening
to the show and watching the show are
Netflix subscribers if Netflix pulls its
money from Georgia I will end my Netflix
subscription I have no interest in
promoting a company that seeks to
devalue my political point of view as a
matter of its business Netflix is in the
business of making entertainment they're
not in the business of shaping political
opinions around the country if they
believe they are then I'm not going to
give my money to them because I don't
give my money money to leftist lobbying
groups and the same thing is true of
Disney I am more than willing to delay
my enjoyment of a Disney
by watching it at home in the comfort of
my home renting it and spending $2.99
instead of 45 bucks to bring my wife and
kids to a to a movie if this is the game
that Hollywood wants to play there will
be consequences
to this game so go for it Hollywood and
make it happen put your money where your
mouth is
or otherwise this is just a bunch of
virtue signaling nonsense and the reason
that you're holding off on pulling from
Georgia is because you want the tax
benefits you want to be able to divert
you signal to all your liberal members
their leftist coterie without actually
having to pull the money also worthwhile
noting while Disney is talking about
pulling all of their production from
Georgia because of the heartbeat bill
you know they also were producing Star
Wars the last Jedi you know where they
filmed Croatia Ireland and Bolivia yeah
at the time Croatia was in Croatia
abortion is still illegal after 10 weeks
in Ireland abortion was illegal overall
in Bolivia abortion wasn't is illegal
didn't see Disney pulling any of its
production from there I'm eager to see
Hollywood be forced to pay higher
production costs by producing only in
countries that agree with it politically
we'll see how they like production in
Sweden pretty pretty incredible stuff
other things that I hate today so
speaking of of brands that are getting
involved in politics in the stupidest
possible way The Associated Press is
reporting that Gucci has what they call
the Cruz 2020 collection it debuted to a
VIP audience this week in Rome it was
themed around the subject of abortion
because I know when I'm buying jeans I'm
thinking about killing babies the
collection featured a purple jacket with
the slogan my body my choice on the back
and a sweater emblazoned with the date
May 22nd 1978 marking the day abortion
became legal in Italy according to the
Associated Press the brand's creative
director Alessandro Michele says the
theme is no coincidence he was inspired
he says by the sudden pro-life
resurgence in the United States the
restrictions in the United States
Michele said made me consider how much
women should be highly respected
sometimes in life choices are difficult
but I believe it is the most difficult
decision for a woman I respect that
decision I respect that decision as I
respect the idea that the uterus is a
garden I wanted to portray the idea that
you interrupted pregnancy does not wipe
out the garden the flower that is the
uterus of every woman well you know what
makes the uterus a garden in this
particular metaphor it would be the fact
that it grows things like a got you know
what the uterus grows
grows any uterus babies and if you kill
the babies it's not really a garden
anymore
now it's just a thing so that's kind of
a weird take again the same logic
applies if we are going to see all of
these brands endorse wild left
sloganeering all they're gonna see is
pop-up brands that do not do this who
are going to pick up the the lion's
share of the of the revenue that leaves
capitalism always wins and if this is
the game that these corporations want to
play there will be consequences to those
games already we'll be back here later
with two additional hours of programming
or we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
robert muller won't go away joe biden
can't be found and ugly guys break their
faces to look hotter finally the mailbag
check it out on the michael and old show